hi there we are back again and this time
we're in the occurred area of Lagos
Nigeria where we meet some people who
are doing some wonderful things with
very unique ideas I'd like to introduce
to you say past the elderly thank you
thanks a posse ideally organization
protector zone had a very brilliant idea
that's right
what they're trying to do is to show the
people around here what they can do to
protect our planet's atmosphere and at
the same time improve food security for
people living in urban areas like labels
so tell us what other support behind is
doing and why Africa is still facing
hard poverty and also extreme hunger by
the year 2050 the population of people
residing in the cities will raise we
increase from 55% to assistances percent
so we'll be having about 10 billion
people in in the world and the majority
of them will be in the city so it's very
important for us to feed them and to get
them fed well you know we need to
strategically place urban farms within
the city so that people can't farm very
close to their houses so that's the
overview of what we are doing protect
ozone has been around for three years
now
and it's clear that you want to stop the
growing of the ozone hole but at the
same time you're involved in urban
gardening and promoting food security
how do all this issues sit together we
need what we call sustainable
agriculture and we can only achieve
sustainable agriculture true or ban
youth participation
we're actually protecting the ozone
layer through the use of waste materials
and also innovations like the 50% what
does even irrigation kit that you saw
yeah you get the youth to be a part of
this you pay them or induce their man
where does your funding come from well
the youth are so passionate I mean one
of the greatest resources we have in
Africa is a man paw not only to grow
food in the urban centers but we're
actually opening them up to
opportunities you know we have a team
that I've attended young African leaders
initiative and stuff like that so we
create opportunities for them and as
touching our funding we get a little
fund from international organizations to
help fight a stream on ground food
in the grassroots the food security or
Venetian is the national security of the
particular nation so we are talking
about insecurity in our country we need
to run produce more food to get people
secured so what we're seeing around here
really is a lot of commitment and
there's no doubt that the participants
here wanted to see the results so how do
you measure your success one of our
participants has about I'm 460 farms you
know not in a particular location about
40 found in different locations you know
in Mingo States so that is a process to
us and we have been getting testimonies
that we have one of our participant that
is actually financing is education from
green food in the city and we also have
some farms do contractors that they need
competent people on their farm so they
can actually trust us to produce
competent people to actually be on their
farms for more food production so what's
next well currently we've affected a bit
over 7500 lives so want to go beyond
that you know and in the year 2018 we're
actually looking at opening up 8,000
urban farms that is backyard farms in
the city and also this our facility
we're actually looking forward to to the
completion of the facility whereby we
have full models of sustainable
agriculture has been practiced in the
cities so that is what we are actually
hearing to achieve thank you thank you
for coming on again